[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today we have
Kristen in Houston Texas hey Kristen
welcome to the show hey thank you very
much for taking my call absolutely how
can we help well my husband and I are in
TR in a financial transition so we've
been paying off our credit card debt for
like the last two years we've been
chasing our tail with it we're due to
pay off our credit card debt by the end
of December maybe the beginning of
January okay coming out great yeah yeah
excited this has been thank you it's
been crazy yeah okay so our next phase
that we want to do is work on building
our savings for down payment and closing
cost to purchase real estate within the
next year or two this year we made two
big decisions well actually we made two
big purchases and one big decision we
we're renters right now and um our rent
was going up and my husband and I
decided okay let's go ahead and move
into an RV well I already had one that
was paid off I've traded that in and we
purchased one and so that's what we're
doing right now is we we have a brand
new RV and we pay space rent so that's
our housing then uh my truck which was
his truck is paid off my truck is paid
off but my truck ended up meeting like
$15,000 of Maintenance and repairs in
the last year and a half just to turn
right around have another $1,00 repair
and we said forget that we need an
upgrade truck for the RV anyway and so
we went ahead and made uh a purchase for
a a truck to pull the RV how much you
spend uh 5 we owe
56623 on it right now 56,000 hold hold
did you say you bought a truck for
56,000 yes it's a
2021 um S250 diesel for
58,000 I'm
shook it was a deal
it was a great deal but our monthly note
is nuts um we've already done that with
our budget and all so and Kristen I'm
gonna just ask the Assumption it's on
payments yeah yeah the payment the
payment is uh 946 and some change W and
we had to yeah it's nuts wa no wait hold
on hold on hold on I gotta call you out
slightly it's the Christmas season so
I'm going to be a little bit
light-hearted first you said it was a
great deal
then you just now turn around and said
it's nuts and just for the record
payment yeah it is nuts it is y'all just
are about to pay off all this credit
card debt you had two paid for trucks
I'm just spelling this out for you okay
well here's here's the thing is uh we we
we thought about this we went through
the budget we uh we did the budget on
the net income not gross and how we
could afford all of that and so we have
it all in the budget and uh everything
together with the truck the RV and the
space rent we're at about $22,100
okay the his truck is a 2012 my truck
HED was a 2011 and high mileage on both
of them we cannot pull the RV with um
either one of his or mine the difference
is and the hard part that you're going
to realize is everything that you have
that money tied up in is going down in
value and I understand that what you
really want is real estate but I don't
think you guys went about the right way
to get there probably not
but given our situation at the time
that's where we were at okay Chang how
much how much can you let's just um real
quick Kristen how much how much could
you sell the truck for
today uh the 21 or the 2011 21 the
$56,000 21 it would have to be 566 okay
so right around there how much could you
sell the r how how much could you sell
the RV
for uh right now it's sitting at 43 so
payoff would probably be around 44 45
okay so you do realize your truck costs
more than where you guys live right okay
so there's just parts of this formula
Chris and I need you to see is not the
wisest choice and I need you to say wow
we should not have we should not have
done this because renting is not
throwing your money away what you guys
did is you chose to take on more debt by
getting an RV and then you chose to have
to go deeper into debt to be able to
move the RV so you just dug yourself
into a deeper hole thinking you know it
was the wisest smartest thing to do at
that point but mathematically
financially it just wasn't it wasn't and
so for you guys you guys have have
stepped backwards a lot in this process
so I almost would say like I would I
want everything to be wiped clean you
guys had such a great track ride with
the credit cards like you were paying
down debt paying down debt no no no no
let me let me tell you right now that
when we were renting he was making lower
income at the time and we were actually
in more debt over our head you could
have gone to a cheaper rent could have
no we couldn't we were
at no wait a sec wait a sec wait a sec
let me draw it back we can't help you if
you don't want help and here's the
here's what I want to here's what I want
to make clear Rachel and I are going to
look at this and we're going to go hey
this is not the smartest choice we want
you to be free and we want you to be out
of debt now here's the difference cuz I
I agree with you in the way that renting
it doesn't feel good it feels like we're
throwing money down a you know down a
black hole no I could care less about
renting that doesn't bother me I'm a
real estate broker okay but what you're
not understanding what you're not
understanding here is it would have been
better for you to rent because rent is
not debt and you're just looking at the
payment per month but you're not looking
at the grand scheme of it okay payment
per month doesn't matter it matters does
that make sense you're looking like oh
$2,100 it's less but I'm like yeah but
you're forgetting about the 56,000 the
43,000 and $ is more than what we were
paying how about this Kristen what you
um for you calling in what was what was
the main question my main question was
you okay it's not changing what we're
doing I understand you know your
philosophy and everything like that and
I understand what we've done and there's
reasons why we did it okay um and and I
understand I I totally agree with you
normal circumstances sure where we're at
right now okay we'll be freeing up about
$3,000 worth of money every month once
we pay off these credit cards okay which
is about to be done at the end of the
month in beginning at next month okay
maybe okay we have $1,000 in savings
every month okay and we have one month's
reserves for bills all of them okay okay
okay how would you best advise to put
that
$33,000 to our debt yeah how much are
you guys making a year Kristen uh in a
year his growth for this year is going
to end up being year to dat it's It's
121 121 okay M so you probably be about
130 U by by the end of the month and do
you add anything to that as well no not
right now okay I will but what I would
broker for a so what I would do Kristen
if you guys choose we just say not to
have I know things in Motors and wheels
that is more than half of your annual
income so if it were me Kristen I would
be selling these two things the truck
and the RV like I said earlier I'd go
rent somewhere free up this money say a
good down payment for you guys to get a
primary home for you and your husband
after 3 to 6 months of expenses I'd put
that in a money market account if you
don't want to do that then the next move
is you have to start paying off this RV
which is
$43,000 and then you need to pay off the
truck before you ever think about real
estates you know I think what's what can
be so hard is we can ourselves talk
ourselves into something and into
situations yeah and be so clouded by
maybe our own judgment our own ways of
thinking that we keep digging ourselves
deeper into a hole and you're thinking
you're on the outside yelling down and
no come out this way come out this way
and I feel like that's what we were
trying to do with her is just to show
and understand it's just the numbers
there's parts of this that you just go
back to just facts and and $900 a month
car payment and and everything so yeah I
mean look
I I am the first one to say when I hear
that kind of talk there's not much we
can do because you've already kind of
painted yourself into this corner of my
ex my situation is the exception and all
of us can find somewhere where we can
say that but you've honestly got to
commit to going okay I've got to just
not make these excuses because all of us
can say well the way my income is set up
or well because we were paying this in
rent or well because all of us can do
that and whenever you do that you
automatically exclude yourself from the
solution you automatically ostracize
yourself from why a plan can't work for
you you just you create you're the
exception and if you want to take on
that identity then that's the identity
you have and nothing nothing we say is
going to be able to help you and I
always hate when that happens because I
am a firm believer Rachel of the idea
that whatever you look for you find it
so if you're always looking for the
reasons that you can't do it then you
never will but the moment you just say
okay I'm going to open up my heart I'm
going to open up my mind a little bit
and just say I'm going to try this plan
I'm going to try something different
yeah because look and I don't say this
to be anything but real when I first
heard your dad talk he's brass like he's
strong like he comes across and I
remember thinking he's got more money
than I do he's he's figured it out he's
not living paycheck to paycheck he's not
in debt I
am so I'm going just leave leave it at
that I'm just leave it at that because
at the end of the day it's like that's
where you like that's the way you have
to see it as okay like I'm still trying
to figure this out I haven't figured it
out yet right someone who has gotten a
handle on it is telling me hey here's
what I did and if you're not going to
take advice from a person who's done it
then you're always going to be kind of
like trying to fight your way out of a
paper bag y yep and like you said the
light somebody's shining the light going
it's this way it's this way yes it's
your choice yep absolutely create your
free every dollar budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life